You only on the executive of the of
the unit or you. I attended when the
rep was away on holidays i
attended in his place but i wasn't
a full executive member. I
was now quietly bassett
filename russell from randwick and.
Kind of moment other names but.
And pat ryan i think was on
the go. Richard richards was
the organiser bagged on the
secretary pretty good talking
fella can't think of his name
he was the president for quite
a few years prior to now quietly
all. Well before now and
i went over there you
know on a break. Many
a time to attend the meetings. Did you
have to also to you were you ever at the
labour council. Attended one conference
and conference but not to belabor council
like it was and i'll peek conference in
the town hall and only attended that once
it's
a boring damn thing to go to unless you're
actively interested since once upon
a time i would no more think of getting
up and speaking publicly but depo started
me off on that you know.
Some people might have
a good brain to think with and everything
else like that but they are not
particularly not not verbally articulate
and they can't put their words in
a meeting and i found myself there
a couple of times being asked. You know. I
know me you can get away with their well
i was anti-family
a union. This is before the
unions merged and. So much so
that when we got deduction of
wages by the. Me department of
you know a union dues to me that was
a step in the right direction when they
made him out of the tramway union they were
always building posed they came out. Try
to come out and i was going to take them
to court but i weakened i could i was i
was really cracking down on the fact
that they discovered this band. You know
so that was one thing so i got up and i
address
a meeting of foiled down could believe it.
I take my belief and then i got up and i
made sense and the most and that i support
it was kelly and that was one thing
but as far as i did
a lot of the back of that truck in man i
mean you know the time things like that we
had to get any war down there. John
armstrong said john armstrong and
senator carl bowers used to come down
support to elections. I worked very hard. I
wasn't the right. But i did work very hard.
I mean you know i would say that i was
one of those people that keep the
banters going just by effort and
goes again applications of the world you
know if you keep out something. And
that's what i did i was working when not
now to brent meaning a day. Why i have
a house shop and there's this.
This matter of contention
came up. And i was working from
male to d y and the terminus
a day. Y was right outside we went up the
stairs so the meeting bagnall was in the
in the you know i'll pay to do
what you do want. So i went about
ten minutes early coming out from any i
mean like hell there parked about where
upstairs move this motion
and seen an architect with
a housing commission and he was another
one that is damaged say. And they were
still going. Half an hour after i do it
and god i never ever thought there was
traditions to. Do i get some
over there. You know so i think
a bomb and fight and then running away but
i had the best community. So you tell me
if you started to tell me if you passed
stories you know driving buses stories
about about buses before when we
were just changing the type of
a well. I can't remember them or you know
store them either. So i don't know what
to say when you were but you were telling
one about speeding krista oh yes
yes. Well. You know driving
a bus number sixteen eleven and will now
be in one of the light of framed our means
not likely allow him is slow change jobs
and i was coming back to denver. Light to
sign off and as i drove over. While
being chill as fast as she got my
foot was right on the accelerator down
the floor and i threw it in neutral. And
remind me
a city where and i was going so fast my
the time i got towards the bottom of the
hill that i got scared and the vibration
was such that i was doing this i was
really being thrown away and. So i applied
the brakes gradually and pulled up.
No passengers in at the time i don't know
where running back special. And but city
where i made a similar
experience a mile but it was
a good place to pick up some speed. He went
down there cowered about over the hill
and he's you know there were two that said
i still don't know how i got through it
and one task here and the other one has
one day where there is and i never hear
these he say was no fault of mine. He
was going too fast to do anything. I
have got and i think that. We ever did you
ever drive any of the heavy albion's as
well you know the old flow change
once yeah yeah you know up
a hill sydney road about two miles an hour
wait five minutes for them to die and
change on the whims you know. We steer the
clutch break it to clutch hard. Count me
and then i think. Well that's an exaggerated
merch what it was like you know.
Have you ever trip in any of the old buses
that have been got at the museum the
tram is there. I haven't seen them. Well
1937 i started on them so you know
i've been to put our i can hit
a funny one about no i would be with the
power they used to have buses for the low
bridge over there and this
particular one ten ten with
a number of it. I think it
was a piece elector. I had
a call on the side for the conductor to
walk along and people said for best.
So. That the one that had the the
engine up the back or on the side or
i forget the engine now i
think it could have been
a sign when i was very much
down the back i saw them over
a bus is there like that and they had to
the entrance was on the front. Yes the
entrance on 10:10 oh i forgot i really can't
remember the other thing about anyway
. The inspector or crowns as we used to
call them got on this bus and appellant
darcy somebody i can't think
we say no. From both depot. He
was standing on the left so much and i was
up must have been the back side and yes
it was come up right there and then in fact
you get on i take your journal examine
the safe side it then they go through
inspecting tickets. So in the bottom deck
meriwether upstairs and he came down.
He says i'm here for two and collected
prayers. Laughter and i said where
father is up there. I'll be
up there he said in the
boat and yes there is no
come up there so i went upstairs and there
specter pointed out to people in front
of both guys it's done
a bloody because it's as i thought
they were on the buses front. So
there was
a story about it and the same
fellow was quick and will take
it when good running back
special. Over. Near.
Him i meant for a time and
a bit to top that completely off. And he
took it back in the depot and booked it up
top take light. Of the
funniest ones i'm going to let
my hair. There's
a bridge the sewer pipe in then and
there. They regularly used to cut the
tops up with that one just the concrete
is all scarred where there are no quite
easy. Yeah. Yes he had quite
a few funny stories on
a man whom i can't make them all who mind
at the moment. But those who were pretty
white are you. Philip and then that bus
used to say about. I don't know but i
meant ten more than anything else and. And
i don't know if you've ever seen in the
corridor alongside i'm serious. Funnily
enough in england on the southdown buses
the country buses were like that. You know.
And of course that they all came from
england in both ways you know used to be
like they were you know we used to it was
about six or seven miles out of eastbourne
where i lived you know under sort of the
south and buses and maidstone district
buses i know. And they were all like that
they had all. I'm not stairs anyway they
had the corridor along one side. Yes well
i i never thought i'd be
a bus driver who used to cheat you know and
late at night. The driver and in fact.
Been my wife knows
a chap time my mother and all the time
he got out one day i came round the back
and that's another i can't
and i know. He said come on
up you go i said when. Is it you know and
i said i said i'm not me. Come on come
on. Anyway i was keen i wanted to but
i was too scared. I didn't even have
a car and i was like so i got in and he
made me drive all the way out of parliament
. This was why and that was my first and
you know. Well you know. So after that we
used to be mothers go. But you always
have your head through the window in case
that was my first experience at the
other one. What he was driving for
managed and they were like and this fellow
took two up front always drunk and you
and that you were in the front
seat. So i got some reps on his
hand and he saw it on the winds when.
Bus pulled up like that out you know i
swear up the stairs. You know it's
a man expected to you and he would sit for
twenty. Weston's hours and when i got up
there. Here is standing arm of those
black and black i've got me into weren't
because that what they said he said i didn't
presume about western i didn't you did
not but. I got certainly should tell him
to and it doesn't matter. He was petrified
. You know i want to find out the one that
appeared out the window that he had no
on the floor. I just i and hoped
and going on the phone and
other kinds and how that turned something
to the cullens is to follow us in the car
. The inspectors the kelly said and i'm
doing them one again and you know.
And coming to coco. Everytime i stop
this money in my in my event and build.
So i couldn't stand it any more. I pulled
up jumped out and went back and i think
if you both. While i'm bloody case
there's bad. Forget about i said so on
and the fellow looked up and said is that
we all lost and there were two women in
the back ten they'd lost her way so they
thought the only safe way was to find bus
again back on the main road and i've
used them if i thought of kelly's. And
that's about all i can think of the moment
you know. You were telling me about
about a time you wrote which was
a venture be published. Yes i'm just i
got put off from the bridge. I tried
everything. And not that
i fancied myself as
a writer but i did limit so feel and
tell me on about an old man having an
injection of much monkey glands. And i
thought it was funny. So i put it into
twelve hours and i can't remember the early
ones like episode long but the payment
just fine the way you know. And the last
time hearses ran like this. The nurse came
out and beckoned me and when i maybe
i think by and i i said monkey when
the nurse came out and beckoned me. But
they were she wasn't certain so far she
said. There's only three but they've already
left the curtain. I cried. I laughed
and then i sang if i cried. I
laughed and then i say if grant
you know i cry no laughs.
And very nearly flattened.
If glands came. Well yeah.
If gran's came for me
and tangs just think what might have
happened and that was it. You know i got ten
sellings from beckett's budget.
It was some points. It was
a weekly. How many verses do you get the
intellect. How many want. How many verses
for ten shillings promises that were i
think i said another one. I mean the poem
and they didn't think much of it and i
never got any more. And so i gave away
. Oh i hope black paint. What
would people want back painful in
the depression era in the depression times
that i didn't sell. I went out to try
and sharpen anything lawnmowers scissors
shears never knew how to sharpen it
still didn't get
a job. I made some toys
and i went out and did
some noughts a door with them monkey on
a stick to test it. My wife came out
with me trying to hawk them. First
up i told sticks for she'll use at
a news agency and by and twelve
another shop on the way home and that
was a teen mom to support
them and i made my sing
a hound's soul and them to
my house and sidney and.
I with that matter would matter would
pay i paid it and you know that when i
made no monkeys and sticks. I planed them
went down to movies with them both and
but i never had any till
i told him that. And we
had to go to paramount to look after the
lines. Till while she was in hospital and
that pay their phantom to parramatta i
would say o'clock in the morning at
nine p.m.
For to finish and then we went
out and to try anything i
more than just for at milton point sold
a moment cremorne pent up. My liberty and
you know the day and i'm pretty good but
yeah i'm finished this time. I don't
believe. You were involved in the
in the disputes with the with the government
bus. The government buses re. The
day off council perhaps you could explain
what what what what this don't cancel
business was well the day i cancelled.
You had two days off a week for
a fortnight and mature
to staff various other
things like that which of course sometimes
may have been brought about by being at
us. After days of cancelled were necessary
they had to get people to do the job so
i believed and it was my contention all
true that my days off my property and that
nobody could make me work on them
if i didn't want to and that was
a principle that i adopted and i think i
may have i could have been suspended over
it but i think the ruster clerks and with
me being active in the union. I don't say
they went quietly on me but the situation
then and i swear i had to do one i
was never compelled to do so i got away
with it. So when the much one mouse
came in i was
a deputy union rep and i had
to why the round with the i do
nothing say nothing observation
from the union's point of view that
the tough guy had that time the strike it
actually happened by that time the first
try cutting debt and that. And that. And
the terms of going back were that there
would be observations of that step as part
of the terms of the settlement that they
go out i would just spend it
several times for points of view.
So we had to go slow and alan horsey
pulled me up and suspended me patterns to
help me amount regulation one to four
people gas and when you have to pass by
drive you up the wall them by the amount
of passengers you know. And where your
test bended that's working
rule working to rule is maybe
a regulation strike they call
now and then i suspend intro
refusing driver batteries squealing backs.
I won that one too. I'm sorry i'm not
back. Exonerated from an ex-con after
pestering the depot master from
a couple of weeks. He said
you're not still on the ice
a turn. I am i said their union and
the partner instructing was such
i said all i needed and that and you
suspended me so i got up and you know. One
meant you had to know that one man
operation in place. And climb government
. One of the first men and rhyme
one mounts down the bookie. He
put in
a nutshell he said instead of striking
over the instant action in one man but as
they turned me fighting to conditions but
when they drive them because they're
going to drive them for two and it was
when i go off and wondered why they didn't
attack that the other way. You know because.
As far as i could see i mean the you
know one man buses have been operation
in various parts of the world. I mean
including the states there but the you
weren't responsible for handling tickets
when you when you were one man but as i
bowl as far as we were concerned. That was
one of the bugbears you know having to be
responsible for the money pull tickets
and everything else like that
but they didn't give the thing
a chance to develop you know you've got
you've got people and landing points
selling the tickets it's
a cop for the driver these days. Providing
and i used to like driving myself i
still like like conducting and i
was a good conductor and i believe
a pretty fair and i mean i don't
i don't remember an accident
that involved
a place. I did push and ask and
seven say that gates once. He
napped i stopped short of the toll going
to town and. It's black and that's us
and sammy mustn't come across like that
and stop there. So i might i just i
move forward slowly macaws and i'm pretty
you know and i know i'm here this way and
when you've got to help more i look
through the fence down here is
a car. I pushed him about six feet. No
damage really because he was up against it.
I spent time in the back. And i tell him
i think look i can't see him from up
a visibility into that i would need
it to either. Go higher but main
problem. Everything will have
to be got over that one for
a while and track where you were driving
buses and there were trams still on the
road if you ever have a sort of you
know you know a long moon boat. We had
a man that might be queen the oils and
that might between the footboard move that
pamphlet i'm saying look i mean shoulder
and dive straight in the tram mcgrattan
mother crowns. Hit me on them of the oil
spill everything else like that in milk
like that there was no nobody like him
and i think he thought that they were
talking probably tie him. Now
the trimmings. Too and they
could pick up quick and passes these
anti-newt now they were known to them
so used to what you see in the top when
you know and that's when we change down
a third time when you know them but they
don't know what is and make so we stopped
once we stopped and that's when the next
time someone that is going all the time
but we always reckon that the only things
came out here that we never you know you
know i was lucky. I drive between
women part mine for many years.
One night i'm coming out from in it and
it pouring down. You can't see the curb.
You can like this where you capitalize
on my ear and i'm way. All my to
look in the back of the bus and then some
of sleep something paper some ten tattoo
anyway. Not if you're
in a world that's not
a gamey confidence. You know i never been
one of the me confident parents. But i
think my team. I was waiting and they
were all happy. You know you were here of
the verses the trip. The trams
trying to ram buses. No one by
deliberately put out the man in one
fight me to make it i didn't have it my
. I abused him in so many times and words
that i called him. But now he's panicked
and. He want to come back and fight me but
he went over the bus and i want you know
they were back and coming forward
on the masses but that was
a mighty between them build it as
a next time and all hell
find that welfare. And
. Tech welfare wanted all night
drama and he and his gun the mills
going to mills work and when the muskegon
saw that coming. They used that when the
call and sweetbreads budget went hand up
on this but print me that time and i think
alec entirely math and i called him. Of
course norms. When we used the stuff from
cal mossman to take up our work mainly
before mookie of before men and
they went down. The spread. And they leave
all the way around. I get the spirit and
then they want to give away their money
but up both sides of print. Bobbsey. Now
impressed that you could believe
it could i went up my first day
on the way my first shift and driver. Had
a big driver buying ten lines
and i got headlights from
a crowd coming and i must i mean the women
and i hit it together and the bus went
like that whom went home and gone
down again. And got off from
people men down from upstairs
and conductors and. People from
a nothing but that fight me and all my
department i had been i hadn't found and
then i went. I was in the swim bike
and i am. After my you can get used
to not letting him right. Why it's
when it's wet and you get the no light
that what the problem was or anywhere
animosity between the bus drivers and and
taxi drivers. So now particularly i
particularly wish to get on pretty well with
them and the place we play
sport against a place like
a matters and football matter. Seems like
a no no no no. And i said you know.
Can you think of any other story you can
think of any other stories about there's
no i won't have
a bit of fun here i'm going back to the
devil and we're just keeping on time. This
girl. I don't know what i'm
going on anyway. She pulled
a make up get out and she tried to do
a lips and i think on the what's the
name of the government further along in
writing. She didn't know what was
going on. So i do it again and after
a while she looked up to my door. She
woke up. It's going on and glared at me
and tell me all to see me
there where that. It was fun.
I really enjoyed my bass when did you come
across any of them in the union case is
about fellas. They were girlfriends
of or their running mate with
a better idea and that was
quite prevalent quite
a lot of them going on. Fairly mate. So
we're supposed to pay and that means.
We didn't have passed. We're all going into
an institute concert and there's about
thirty of us. So what fred did he
reach thirty tickets up you know
content and i think it takes to go through
that you've got a star in tickets up
a game to somebody if your crowd
gets on punch. So you've got
a lot of credit and i don't know we didn't
have to show that was one of the ways
sheet. Oh and. Collins. I
don't know call now and
mainly used to live in golf quite it was
our speed booking but he had survived
a sad sight of his body so he had to get
in and they can't stand under the stairs.
How do you about four stops
then. So they ought to try and
that was. How will and they fire team
crowns got him once for unpaid face
a. But the only time he has to stand
on the stairs and i used to tell him.
It's
a crowd i'm tired i'm last stop. But he
said when the crowd after he said next stop
. Next stop not last of the guy last
night to conduct i may not have had
a chance of getting
a thing. But they got it back to front i
said. Next stop. You have to put himself
in you know that you know nothing.
They have done. That's one month and
something else. Pop up. All right well
thank you very much mr. Mccarver.